[Music]
you
just tapped into the group chat in the
bleacher report app presented by fanduel
i'm greg ivory alongside live moods liv
how you feeling today
you know what
you know what i'm feeling a whole lot
better than the last time that we talked
because i just avoided
not getting swept give us the small
victories because that's all we've got
right now is these little small
victories we didn't get swept it was a
great game so i'm feeling pretty good on
a monday greg feeling pretty good liz
feeling good i need everybody clapping
emojis for the nuggets not getting swept
in the comments
let's let's give it up let's give it up
to the nuggets but uh i'm giving away
locks i'm giving away hoodies jerseys
and those brand new br betting
basketball shorts
so make sure you guys get in the
comments i need gifts i need emojis i
need clapping emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
in fact live i'm giving out some of
those shorts right now
i got michael bowling almost get rich
o'clock shout out to you michael bowen
he also says liv is back
uh kyrie is ready for the flat earth
cruise frida felter 78 says that i guess
he's saying kyrie is going home today uh
shout out to hugh freda uh we got one
more let him drop 25 plus four games in
a row
egypt syria
73 shout out to everybody i mentioned
you guys are all walking away with
shorts liv
it's game day so you know
we over here at br betting we gotta bet
the three by two so the question is will
there be two three-pointers in the first
three minutes of the game we asked you
on twitter with the 3x2 cache tonight
there it is we got the celtics taking on
the nets the raptors taking on those
76ers jazz mavericks those are the odds
you guys see him uh and here are the
current results there they are
no surprise to me brooklyn and boston is
taking the poll at 47 uh rounded off by
philadelphia toronto dallas and the jazz
lift
you see what the people are thinking you
see what the audience is thinking but
the people and me i want to know what
are you thinking which 3x2 are we riding
today
yeah i'm with the public on this one
normally i fade the public here but i
think the 3x2 that makes the most sense
tonight is the celtics and the nets i'm
hoping that the nets come out with a
little bit of energy take some
three-point shots early despite their
record in this series they actually have
the third best three-point percentage in
the playoffs right now so that celtics
perimeter defense has been lacking a bit
so i like them to take some shots early
the celtics the same way jason tatum
taking some shots early even marcus
smart al horford
so i think i'm with the public on this
one normally i fade y'all but i think
you guys are on the right side tonight
so i'm gonna rock with the three by two
with the celtics and the nets
liv is rocking with the public wow she's
rocking with the public she's walking
with the brook and that's boston celtics
but i'm in the comments because i want
to see liv i want to see what they are
talking about in the comments i see
mkint93 says
net celtics definitely cashes um
c
road four says little head
dude jason tatum going for 38. he says
jason tatum is gonna have a good game
shout out to you chris uh i got one more
one more mzg says he got brooklyn
winning so do i
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh liv
i'm gonna make the call i'm gonna make
the call
we are riding as a family everybody is
riding with you we are riding with the
audience we are riding with the brooklyn
nets
boston celtics three by two that is the
squad ride of the day we need to hit
that but it's my favorite part of the
show live let's talk major markets money
lines against the spreads and point
totals for tonight's game let's take a
look at the odds liv what are you
thinking here anything that sticks out
to you
yeah i'm actually really liking the mavs
tonight to be honest with you they
should be up 3-1 in this series
obviously that buzzer beater from last
game probably got them a little bit
fired up i think they're going to come
out swinging with a little bit of
revenge they're back home luca is
healthy i think luca goes off tonight so
i'm gonna back the home team tonight in
the mavericks who i believe should
actually be up in this series right now
i think they're gonna be hot-headed from
that buzzer beater last game so give me
the mavs because the utah jazz are a
betting liability so i'm going to rock
with the mavs tonight
i like that liv i i like that i do like
that pick i do the mavs at home
they can bounce back tonight and i can
see this being a great spot hey why not
parlay you guys like parlays you guys
talk about parlays all the time
i'm gonna rock with the brooklyn nets
here i just don't think that they're
gonna get swept
at home
kyrie kd
got to have a bounce back game i'm just
feeling them to have a bounce back game
so i'm rocking with the nets
but why not mix in liv's pick
nets mavericks little moneyline parlay
hey we're all trying to get rich here so
uh that's who i'm rocking with but let
me hop into these comments because it's
time to give out
some of these hoodies as you can see i
got one on uh net moneyline they avoid
the sweep jojo four three four five four
shout out to you
dj fitz says didn't what he is dropping
buckets tonight i can see that happening
my man spencer is a bucket uh
i got
whoa the comments are jumping mavs get
the dub r
williams223 shout out to you everybody
that i mentioned you all are walking
away with hoodies uh live we talked
major markets now let's talk player
props it's time for lock or not i'm
gonna put up a prop and i need all of
you to get in the comments and tell me
if it's a lock or it's not let's start
off with luka doncic slip will he score
over 30 points tonight it's sitting at
-110
talk to me talk to the people
is this a lock or not
i mean yeah it's luca he's back he was
obviously uh he had an injury there for
a minute didn't even know if we were
gonna see him in this series uh but we
are now and it's luca at home i think
he's gonna put on a show for sure he's
averaging 30 points versus the jazz this
season um and he's a playoff guy you
know if there's any guy that i trust in
the playoffs to get the job done to
fight uh it's going to be a guy like him
so i really do like him for 30 plus
tonight i'm gonna rock with luca i think
it's a lock
i'm right there behind you liv i'm i'm
right there behind you last game luca
came back from his injury he dropped 30
34 minutes played
i literally have a question for
everybody that's watching and live chime
in if you have an answer
who's going to guard him like who on the
jazz
can guard luca donches i
i literally can't name that one person
that i think that can guard luca doncic
so therefore i mean i'm just connecting
the dots liv i'm riding with you i'm
locking in luca over 30 points
i can see them getting it done they're
at home
but uh
let me hop into these comments let me
hop into these comments
and see what they're talking about i got
tb m sean says under ooh wow he's going
with the under shout out to you you're
still walking away with hoodie but i
gotta get some good vibes in here caleb
poland luca lock 36 points and the win
i like those vibes shout out to both of
you both are walking away with some
shorts next up we have rudy gobert over
14 rebounds live it's sitting at minus
128.
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one
i do i think rudy gobert is gonna play
with some intensity tonight obviously
i'm sure he and a lot of other people
feel like he was snubbed a defensive
player of the year this year um he is
that guy i never really worry about
rebounds when it comes to rudy gobert
especially when he's facing a mavs team
that in the last seven games have given
up the fourth most rebounds to opposing
centers at around 19 per game so 14 for
him although it's a huge number for rudy
it's really not that big um he's hit
this quite a few times throughout the
series so i'm liking him for 14 plus
tonight because i think he comes out
swinging with a little bit of aggression
on defense for sure
liv is locking it in liv is locking it
in usually i like to stay away from you
know these big numbers and rebounds but
we're talking about rudy gobert here
he last game last game hey he's a little
spark lit up under rudy he's out there
moving around got the got the big shot
uh
so liv you know what i'm i'm going to go
against my own grain i'm going to go
against my own grade he had 17 rebounds
last game uh he also had 17 rebounds in
another game in this series
can he do it again tonight luca's going
to be shooting the ball a lot so
therefore i'm rocking with you
liv i'm rocking with rudy gobert to get
this over i'm calling it a lock sitting
at minus 128 rudy go grab those 14
rebounds uh let me hop into the comments
though because i want to see what
they're talking about
i like this uh purplerain99 says seth
curry over one and a half assists
jason tatum over five and a half five
and a half assists
and jaylen brown over five and a half
assists parlay that and you are welcome
those are a lot of assists that means
the ball is going to be moving in that
game but i like it i like it a lot uh i
also see mitchell nero net celtics first
basket winner bruce brown
and the nets to win is plus 2400
they're trying to win some money in the
comments live they're trying to win some
money they're just dropping all type of
different bets but uh shout out to
youtube for the takes you guys are
walking away with some shorts uh
let's get back to this game because we
have donovan mitchell to talk about that
is the last prop we're talking about and
i want to know if he's gonna make over
two three pointers today live talk to me
talk to the people do you think do you
think this one is a lock or not
yeah i mean donovan mitchell anything
really seems like a lock i mean he's a
very efficient shooter and scorer um and
i think he's going to be challenged a
lot by luca tonight in terms of uh who's
scoring the most points and taking the
most threes i think luke is going to
take a lot of three-point shots i think
donovan mitchell will follow suit and
also take a lot of three-point shots i
don't think he'll have any problems
hitting that two plus threes especially
in a playoff game especially against the
mavs and they're on the road i think
he's gonna put up a fight so two plus
three's for donovan mitchell i think
it's a lock tonight
liv's calling it a lock
and i honestly live
i think that this really can't happen i
really do we're talking donovan mitchell
he's one of the best shooting guards in
the league like
he could easily knock down two threes
but as i look to the right of the screen
and i see that minus 142 that's where i
just uh
start to scratch my head a little bit
and think to myself do i really want to
put that value on donovan mitchell to
make two threes
and tonight i just don't think that i'm
gonna do that i don't think that i'm
gonna put the value in donovan mitchell
we see how the mavericks are attacking
him uh on defense and
i'm going to stay away from it i'm just
going to stay away from it i'm not going
to touch it but that doesn't mean you
guys might not touch it so i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments seeing
what they are talking about
i want to win says donovan mitchell's
two three-pointers oh man over lock it
in they also said donovan mitchell is
going to be lights out tonight uh ace
boogie 717 says
d mitch and luca are going to go
off
vr betting says one minus 142 is a
little scary shout out to everybody that
i mentioned you all are walking away
with shorts
but live it's time to build the br
betting custom same game parlay which
you can ride along with us on fanduel
tonight we are looking at the celtics
nets game and i need everybody to get in
the comments and tell me what they think
which legs or locks which legs or not
let's get right to it first off we're
starting off
with kyrie irving liv we were talking
off camera you
told me about a video you showed me a
video of kyrie walking into the arena
and i'll just say
i'm i'm kind of nervous about this 25
plus points bet
after watching that video but how are
you feeling how are you feeling you
think kyrie can go out there and get us
25 points tonight
well i'll be honest with you that video
doesn't make me feel great about
anything kyrie related tonight because
the dude looks defeated he looks like
someone walking into their 9-5 job that
they absolutely hate he just does not
look like he's in it tonight at all
however we know kyrie's a little bit of
a strange dude and maybe that's just his
way of processing where they're at and
and maybe that's his uh his game face i
don't know it looked like a pretty uh
interesting game face i've never seen
one like that before but he he can be an
oddball so i'm not super you know
worried about him not showing up and
showing out i think that he's the type
of guy that even if the nets go down
he's still going to want to put on a
show and he's at least gonna fight for
it he's been scoring pretty well against
the celtics team in comparison to guys
like kd so
i'm not gonna stress it too much 25 plus
for kyrie i hope they come out swinging
and try to get a win tonight so i'm
gonna say
it's good we just maybe sweating it a
little bit
i like those vibes live i like those
vibes let's move on
to jason tatum
now
we need jason tatum to score 30 points
this literally seems like a layup
he's been absolutely balling this series
live talk to me talk to the people do
you think jason tatum can go out there
and
score 30 tonight
i mean like you said layup he's been
doing very well uh he's been scoring
very efficiently against the nets the
nets have struggled with defense all
season long we saw that in the regular
season um so he he's just yeah he's out
there just shooting the ball and it
seems pretty effortless for him i will
say uh he's had a lot of help
offensively in this series guys like al
horford have been showing up mark is
smart
jaylen brown has even been pretty
consistent so he doesn't necessarily
need to drop 30 points in order for the
celtics to stay in this game or win this
game so that's my only reservation with
this leg but again he's been doing it
throughout the series it's a layup for
him so jason tatum he's he's bound to
have another 30 plus game tonight for
sure
feeling good about that leg lift feeling
really good about that leg let's move on
to
his teammate
jaylen brown can he go out there and
score 20 points tonight we only need 20.
we only need a dove piece
can jaylen go get it for us yeah
i i do i do i mean normally uh jaylen
broad is not a guy that i like to bet on
from a player perspective i just think
he's a little too inconsistent and
obviously health and injuries have a lot
to do with that so it's not just him as
a player he's obviously had some health
issues
throughout the season but he's not a
player i typically like to bet on uh
just because of those inconsistencies
however in this series he has hit this
number in every game so far so he is
definitely showing a lot more
consistency in the playoffs than he did
in the regular season so i do trust him
to score 20 plus tonight because i think
the celtics want to finish this off
tonight um and call it a sweep so i
think he'll have a big role tonight in
20 plus i feel good about it
liv feels good about it i don't feel
good about them sweeping the nets
because you know that's one of my bets
today
but
hopefully you can make me feel even more
good about this parlay as we round it
off with my man kevin durant i call him
kd or slim
whatever i like whatever flows off the
tongue uh but that's that's that's kevin
durant one of the best basketball
players in the league right now just had
to make that statement uh but he
he hasn't kind of been playing like it
but can he turn it around today liv can
he turn it around today and knock down
two three pointers to help
complete our parlay do you think my guy
kd can go knock down two threes today
yeah i do i really do and i think uh
everyone's been waiting for katie's
bounce back game you know after game one
it was oh that was just a bad night like
he's gonna bounce back game two he
didn't um and there's a reason he didn't
and it's called celtics defense and they
have been really really tight on him but
i think something that is
that i have learned about katie just
from following him on twitter he's
pretty funny on twitter so if you don't
follow him you absolutely should he
loves being underestimated he loves the
chatter he loves when people are
doubting him and there's a lot of
conversations right now about is kd as
good as everyone thinks he is he's down
0-3 in a series hasn't been playing well
at all i think this is a really
important game for him to prove the
haters wrong he is one of the best
players in the league
and this series doesn't really change
that he's just up against really great
defense however the celtics like i said
their perimeter defense has been lacking
uh the nets have the third best
three-point percentage so this is a
great opportunity for katie to shut the
haters up and hit two plus threes and i
think he can do it tonight
i also think he can do it if anybody's
questioning kevin durant's greatness
just turn on the tv screen and watch the
man play or go look up some youtube
highlights hey this is one of the best
to do it uh but let's put this ticket up
let's put this ticket up so i can show
you guys if you guys would go spend 100
on our parlay you are walking away with
414.29
live talk to me talk to the people what
are you grading the parlay today
yeah i'm gonna give it a b not because i
don't love the parlay but because i
think betting on the nets right now is
just an automatic sweat it's it's not a
comfortable bet you want to make any of
the players player props whatever it is
it's going to be a sweat so i'm going to
give it a b because i like it i think
these are all four guys that know how to
show up in a playoff situation uh the
nets have their backs against the wall
tonight so they really need to show up
so i think it's a great parlay but i
think
get your sweat towels it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a tough one to uh to sit
through but i think they can do it
everybody get your sweat towels ready
important to live
but she does think that we can get it
done so there's good vibes at the end of
the tunnel we just got to get there oh
look it i'm in the comments and i see
good vibes my man richie 21 sent us a
sunset you guys know sunsets
it's way too i mean i love sunsets wait
in my heart uh
so shout out to you richie you are
walking away with
some shorts i also got g quinn 26 b
minus we got this thing tonight you know
why he said it's why he said b minus
live i know why he said b minus he said
b minus usually when libs gives us b
minuses we win and he's a yeah g quinn
you know i know why you did that you're
walking away with hoodie i got one more
bad sport takes says all these are locks
except kyrie he won't be trying tonight
uh i mean based on the video we saw i
kind of can concur that but hopefully
he's putting on a show it's kyrie you
know he he's just
he's in his kobe mentality it's a mind
game it's a mind game you know you know
what i'm talking about levy making it
seem like he's not invested but the
man's about to go exactly off tonight so
hopefully that's the vibe that's going
on but all right we've all right you've
seen our parlay
now let's talk a little bit more about
the matchups tonight
before we get into it here are the
current series odds going into tonight's
game
nets really got some good value right
there as you guys can see i don't know
about you guys but i know these odds are
not in the favor of the nets but i'm
feeling a little fade
today as a matter of fact so much so
that we are about to hook y'all up with
a br betting
fanduel custom boost for the nets talk
to him live that's right we have teamed
up with our friends over at fanduel and
are hooking you guys up with a special
boost we've got kyrie irving to score 25
or more points which is in our same game
parlay so we absolutely need it and for
the nets to win boosted from plus 165 to
plus 210 you know how we like that plus
money great value there yes yes i'm
really rocking with that odds boost i'm
really rocking with that hey liv i i am
rocking with this one as well i mean you
know what we like to do we like to
connect docs i said the nets are gonna
win i don't think that they're gonna get
swept you said you felt really good
about kyrie
making 25 uh scoring 25 points tonight
when we were talking about our parlay
hey we're just connecting the dots here
and you guys know we like plus money i
like it liv i i love i love this play uh
you guys
have heard from us but now we want to
hear from you we asked you in the app if
you're riding our nets boost or if you
think they are getting swept tonight i
need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me if you are riding with us or
against us
let me get into these comments because i
want to see i i gotta see who's riding
with us go guardian a mating boost thank
you br fanduel thank you go garden uh
for tapping in with us uh i got m kent
93 says celtics all day no way nets can
hang okay gareth gd23
says i bet no one outside of toronto and
a few die-hard sisters fans watch that
game again
i i i guess so uh
ala mendoza dubs going to the finals
shout out to you i'ma keep going liv i'm
just gonna keep going it's time to give
away some of these hoodies i like the
value let's make this money sprinkle a
couple units gabriel donaius shout out
to you everybody that i mentioned you
all are walking away with hoodies by the
way i just want to let you guys know
that brady p13 absolutely riding kyrie
is going to go crazy i i think so kyrie
kyrie's gonna go crazy
greg i literally i'm sorry
i'm i'm interrupting because listen i've
been keeping this inside it's been
bubbling up i let you talk your trash
last week now it's my turn like i said
thursday i had a feeling the nuggets
would steal one at home
i'm celebrating the small victories i
warned you at the beginning of the show
i gotta know i gotta know what was your
reaction to the nuggets winning that
game
i need more clapping emojis in the
comments cuz let's all give a round of
applause
to the denver nuggets for winning game
one hey finally y'all at the dance live
y'all here y'all showed up about time i
was waiting i've been waiting on you
guys like to actually show we were
giving you guys like we were giving you
a head start that's what we were doing
you know fair
that's that that that's fair but in all
seriousness uh
it was a really really good game i was
watching it with my dad and i told him
you know champions win this game it was
five minutes left the warriors was down
by like seven and uh this before
draymond green
found out i was talking about that i'm
like hey dad champions go and win this
game and uh i guess the warriors did not
go win the game that is okay that is
okay
i i feel really strong
going back to san francisco draymond
green found out i mentioned that earlier
that kind of played a part in the
nuggets pulling away but
it's a brand new day on it's a brand new
day when they play in san francisco and
i think the warriors can get it done in
the next matchup but liv talk to me
talk to the people
you're a nuggets fan
how did it feel finally showing up to
the series
yeah you know i think obviously i'm not
naive y'all i'm a big denver nuggets
girl of course but i know that the
warriors have the momentum in this
series i do think that that game was
really important for the nuggets just to
gain momentum not within this series but
just for next season i think they had a
lot of
adversities they'd had to climb through
this season obviously pj dozier was out
early jamal murray didn't return mpj out
with an injury so they've been able to
accomplish a lot with what they've had i
think this last game um a lot of the
guys stepped up and helped out jokic
which is something he's needed all
season you saw great moments from will
bart and monte morris bones highland
rookie coming off the bench
shooting the lights out of the place he
had a little jordan cool steph curry
vibe in there for a little bit he was
really really putting on a show so i
think it's great for guys like that you
also saw austin rivers have a little bit
more aggression on defense so to see
these guys kind of get in their groove
and gain some momentum
not just for this series but for the
following season i think was really
great for them just to kind of see that
hey we have the talent we just got to
figure out how to use it so i'm happy
i'm proud um but i'm also not naive and
i know that the warriors have the
momentum and the nuggets have a really
really tough matchup waiting for them so
not letting myself get too excited but
proud of them nonetheless
liv as long as you know what time it is
that's all that matters
that's literally that's all that matters
i do oh but you guys have heard of an uh
yeah that's all that matters but you
guys have heard of nuts from us we want
to hear from you are the nuggets
taking another game in the series on
wednesday or can the warriors
win it all
i need to see you guys in the comments i
want to know uh i
i got
mkent93 says a rough time to be a
nuggets fan yeah i agree with liv's
making it she's she's
embracing it she's embracing it i am uh
tdm shawn tdm sean says series over
warriors win in the next game or
williams223 says pool had a bad game
won't happen next game i totally agree
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with hoodies
live
we reached the end of the show
it's time to get on the body here thank
you guys for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today the 3x2 is a lock the br
betting same game parlay is a lot and we
will be back here next monday giving out
hoodies jerseys and more locks
he won a prize today we will dmu
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory we
are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you